[Musik]
jetzt gerade ist die spannendste Zeit um
auf der Welt zu sein
noch nie in der Menschheitsgeschichte
wurde so viel erlebt so viel erfunden
erforscht hinterfragt und verändert noch
nie gab es so viel Wissen und die
Möglichkeit so viel über unser Universum
unsere Umwelt und uns selbst zu erfahren
jetzt gerade ist aber auch die Zeit in
der es vielleicht die meisten
Herausforderungen gibt noch nie gab es
so viele Menschen auf unserer Erde noch
nie so viele Krisen so viele Probleme
die dringend gelöst werden müssen
deswegen ist jetzt gerade die wichtigste
Zeit wir müssen Lösungen finden
Entscheidungen treffen und Wissen
vermitteln und genau deswegen gibt es Dr
Watson
wir sind ein unabhängiges Team aus
wissenschaftsbegeisterten und wollen mit
euch zusammen über die spannendsten die
wichtigsten und die genialsten Ideen
unserer Zeit sprechen wir wollen euch
erklären wie die Welt funktioniert
welche Zukunftstechnologien unser Leben
verändern und welche
Forschungsergebnisse was zu bedeuten
haben wir wollen das Wissen dieser Welt
an euch weitergeben einfach verständlich
entspannenden Videos mit Minecraft
Faktor jede Woche hier auf Dr Watson
bleibt neugierig
[Musik]